sait on prend les paris on nous n'allons
pas abandonner les kurdes c'est ce
qu'assure donald trump dans un tweet cet
après midi nous continuons à les aider
financièrement et en envoyant des armes
en revanche ce que confirme le président
américain c'est le retrait des troupes
des cinq bases américaines situées dans
leur projet va c'est à dire le kurdistan
syrien alors il ya des fois il ya des
coups de théâtre il ya des volte face
ce qui est intéressant c'est le débat
qui est posée d'un côté on a un point de
vue notamment défendue par donald trump
qui dit il faut que les guerres sans fin
se termine c'est ce qu'ils disent
notamment dans le clip que vous pouvez
dire
et d'un autre côté on a une ministre des
armées en france qui s'inquiètent en
écoute france paris le combat contre des
shu est un combat de longue haleine
il a besoin d'être mené sans faille
donc je ne voudrais pas que les
événements des dernières 24 heures les
annonces des dernières 24 heures ne
créer une diversion dangereuse vous
partager l'inquiétude de florence parly
ou le pacifisme de donald récupérer côté
avant de venir parce que je fais mon
boulot j'ai regardé la revue foreign
affairs il ya un article passionnant ce
d'un certain brett mcgurk qui a été
l'envoyé spécial d'obama dans cette
région c'est lui qui était en charge de
monter la coalition qui a permis aux
forces démocratiques syriennes soixante
mille combattants kurdes mais pas
seulement de tenir de virer des shs de
mettre fin au califat et ce type
expliqué que trump avait pris sa
décision en réalité dès décembre parce
qu'il y avait déjà un tweet de trump qui
disait nous avons gagné contre deich
maintenant il faut ramener les garçons
et les filles à la maison et qui avait
promis donc ce désengagement
or dix personnages importants de
l'administration américaine qui a
démissionné aussitôt que trois pas fait
cette annonce la présence militaire
américaine 2000 hommes des services
spéciaux des forces policières spéciales
américaines était nécessaire pourquoi
pour quatre raisons dit il un empêcher
le retour de l'état islamique parce que
n'oublions pas qu'elle est quarante
mille personnes venues du monde entier
qui sont vus débarquer faire des crimes
commettre des crimes contre l'humanité
créer un état islamique
une espèce de plaies au coeur du monde
du moyen-orient de il s'agissait aussi
de tenir en lisière l'impérialisme
iranien dont on les iraniens ont mis la
main sur l'irak c'est une c'est une
calamité
maintenant ils sont arrivés jusqu en
syrie et ils sont aux portes aux portes
d'israël
on a vraiment on a une guerre pendante
au moyen-orient parce que les israéliens
vont certainement pas laisser les
milices iraniennes à proximité de la
frontière 3 il fallait contenir la
turquie or là ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
livre nos alliés kurdes aux eaux turques
c'est un crime monstrueux enfin c'est
que c'est quelque chose quand on a
utilisé des supplétifs
quand les armes et qu'on leur a dit on
leur a donné une mission qui était de
détruire des shs et qu'ensuite on leur
tire dans le dos en leur disant
maintenant on vous livrer à erdogan
parce que c'est aussi notre allié dans
l'alliance atlantique et que entre un
allié et vous on a choisi celui ci alors
c'est une crapule
c'est vraiment c'est pas seulement une
erreur politique c'est un set un crime
moral
quatrièmement quatrièmement il fallait
que les états unis et et nous parce que
nous sommes dans le même bateau
on est une carte dans les négociations
sur leur sur la réorganisation de la
syrie face à la russie là les américains
sont en train de déchirer la carte visa
vers qui était effectivement les deux
mille soldats qui qui entraînait les
soixante mille combattants des forces
démocratiques et c'était pas rien
c'était un territoire très grand avec
plusieurs millions d'habitants qui sont
derrière l'euphrate
si on les livre si on livre nos alliés
kurdes à erdogan
on aura commis un des pires crimes
depuis les accords de munich en 1938 je
suis scandalisé que donald trump
président des états unis agissent avec
une telle légèreté promis compliqué
parce qu'en même temps je viens de dire
qu'il le faisait plus enfin un jour et
dit qu'il le ferait gens qui ne fait pas
on sent bien que c'est quand même son
projet et ses sombres et parce que c'est
son engagement électoral il a dit il a
dit à ses électeurs on va ramer les boys
a maintenant c'est fini tout ça ça sert
à rien toute façon entre oracle et sur
la clé donc on va et c'est une honte ce
qu'on est en train de faire aux kurdes
cc c'est ce qu'ont toutes choses égales
à mémé c'est ce qu'on a fait aux harkis
c'est à dire qu'on laisse des gens qui
se sont battus pour nous quand on fait
le boulot à notre place on les laisse se
faire soient massacrés par les syriens
soient récupérées par les turcs et les
massacres euros ou qui les utilisent
enfin c'est absolument monstrueux d'un
point de vue moral
il ya tous les inconvénients
géopolitique que vient de très bien dire
brice et notamment le grand en fait on
laisse cette zone au à l'iran d'un côté
à la russie de l'autre bon ben voilà
maintenant faut le dire parce que c'est
la même chose en irak
aussi est il ya un troisième problème là
pour le coup brice n'a pas évoqué ce
sont les djihadistes aujourd'hui ce sont
les kurdes qui détiennent plusieurs
milliers peut-être dizaines de milliers
de djihadistes
or même jusqu'à 100000 donc ces gars là
sont revenus par les que parce que les
clubs qui les ont battus les ont faits
prisonniers pour nous il est là donc
qu'est ce qui va se passer si on lâche
les kurdes les kurdes et déjà vous plus
surveillée les camps et donc les gars
vont vont partir et de deux choses l'une
bastien il serait pas tout de suite dans
la nature soit les turcs les récupère et
vont s'en servir comme ils l'ont déjà
fait comme une arme contre nous et donc
chaque fois qu'on dira car dogan qu'on
veut pas ceux ci comptent pas cela comme
par hasard hop
il y aura un contingent de jadis qui
arrivera alors la question c'est si on
dénonça c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
il ya une chose les cures disent
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont se tourner vers
damas et vers la russie
christophe une question qu'on a posé la
france doit-elle s'engager à protéger
les kurdes d'une éventuelle offensif
turc en syrie on a 1000
mille militaires français qui sont
déployées sur la zone irak syrie est ce
qu'il faut renforcer les disputes
vous imaginez le risque politique du
président français si l'essai c'est nos
gars et nos filles faire ça me parlait
ça me paraît politiquement très dur en
revanche peut-être que là il y aurait
une initiative européenne possible c'est
à dire qu' il est temps qu'il est temps
qu'il est temps c'est bien de dire j'ai
tout à fait d'accord est ce qui a été
dit et par brice et par alexis il
faudrait véritablement peut-être se
manifester très vite avec au moins une
carte européenne dans la mesure où on a
des troupes est capable de troupes
françaises d'ailleurs il ya des troupes
européennes très peu en très petit nom
mais qui sont quand même là deuxièmement
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est que qu'est-ce que l'électorat de
trempe on a affaire strictement rien des
kurdes ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup
mais troisième manche ce qui me fait un
petit peut espérer c'est que vous avez
vu que dans le camp républicain c'est la
première fois que je vois autant de
protestation contre trump il est
véritablement lâché par le parti par les
responsables par les hauts
fonctionnaires et je pense que on voit
d'ailleurs bien qu'il hésite beaucoup et
que alors qu'il a en plus son problème
des pitchs peinture sur les bras il est
en train quand même de grillé beaucoup
de cartouches
je ne sais pas une métaphore en
l'occurrence il rit beaucoup de
cartouches en même temps et c'est le
dernier petit espoir que j'ai que j'ai
pour les kurdes tout temps de sa chanson
dans la phrase je consacrais que c'est
pire qu'un crime
c'est une véritable faute babineau
effectivement dit de la trahison trump
envers les kurdes est critiquée au sein
même de son propre camp on a beaucoup de
réactions
on a simplifié le problème en faisant
des kurdes et alliés parfait sur le long
terme leur indépendantiste ne pourra
composer problème estime mme aka bony
tôt et un autre
un autre internaute nous disait le même
d'ailleurs le problème c'est que le pkk
et l'ipg syriens sont syrie sont liés or
le pkk est bel est bien considérée comme
terroriste en france
alors en fait on parle beaucoup de
géopolitique internationale mais ce qui
est très intéressant c'est aussi ce qui
se passe en interne dans les pays et les
échéances électorales effectivement
trump à une échéance électorale son
électorat se fiche complètement de la
preuve du problème des kurdes mais il a
besoin de ses alliés républicains qui
pour l'instant sont en train de vivement
critiquer mais de l'autre côté on à
erdogan aussi qui se sent d'une certaine
façon agressé je vous rappelle que et le
trump vient d'aller mettre des des
troupes en grèce ce qui pose un vrai
problème aussi à erdogan dans sa façon
de gérer ses relations avec les états
unis
et en l'occurrence erdogan il semblerait
qu'il ait déjà le feu vert de moscou et
de téhéran pour pouvoir envahir la zone
kurde et là il peut décider aussi
finalement de passer à l'action même si
trump te revient sur sa décision et moi
c'est ça qui m'inquiète le plus c'est
que trump peut effectivement revenir et
dire ben de façon électorale je ne peux
pas me permettre ce genre de choses mais
ça sera peut-être déjà trop tard parce
que les provocations rond a été trop
loin parce que je rappelle qu erdogan
c'est quelqu'un qui rigole absolument
pas à équilibrer les jeux les ors de
l'américain le problème le problème
français
le problème c'est le problème c'est que
nous européens on va avoir de grosses
difficultés à négocier avec lui parce
que lui il a aussi une marge de
négociation qui est de lâcher chez nous
les millions de personnes qui sont dans
ces camps et qu'il est qu'il est censé
retenir donc on n'est pas nécessairement
en situation de force non plus pour
négocier avec lui donc c'est un problème
effectivement qui est qui qui est aussi
bien de politique intérieure que
politique internationale et
effectivement c'est une poudrière
selon vous la france doit-elle protéger
les kurdes de l'offensive turque en
syrie fait le buzz elle
comment la colocation cvt est loupée
table là c'était doit-elle donc
effectivement doit-elle là vous êtes 69
pour ça à nous dire oui maintenant la
question est de savoir comment enfin ce
que vous me disiez
mais inspiré ma fait remettre en mémoire
ce que disait sein d un des penseurs
jean petit français qui est trop tôt
disparu qui s'appelait christian malisse
qui dit les politiques étrangères sont
souvent dictées par les considérations
domestiques c'est à dire dans les
guerres du